Yeah,
I don't think it can
the,
I mean what it,
the only way to the,
China's got this big problem which is so
much of it's a reserves are tied up in
dollars so that if it were to cut off
the credit line in dollars,
uh,
how would it maintain the,
exchange rates,
the fixed exchange rate that it has.
I mean it would only be able to really
do that if it allows the yuan to
appreciate.
And so it's buying these,
it's accumulating dollars because they
sell goods to the US,
the dollar show up in China.
What do you do with those dollars?
Well,
you can either buy treasuries with them,
you can hold them in green piles in the
bank,
but that's really the same thing.
You can
buy goods in the US,
which is what we would like them to do.
And if I,
I mean I think ultimately that's what
should happen.
I think ultimately China will decide
they will are a big player in the
international economy.
They will not be able to maintain the
fixed exchange rate.
They'll have to go to a floating
exchange rate and they're a dollars that
they own will depreciate because you
won,
will appreciate relative to the dollar,
so that in fact some of their nest egg
will be eroded by doing that.
And so they're not anxious to do this.
They prefer the status quo.
All the talk they have,
in my opinion about the US doing,
moving this special drawing rights or
some other kind of reserve currency
isn't really what they want.
They like the status quo the way it is
now and I think they're going to
continue this way,
uh,
as long as they possibly can,
but ultimately are going to let the.
They're going to have to let the economy
open.
It's just too big and economy.
You can't.
You can't run it without allowing
capital flows in and out.
I think what's going to ultimately
happen if,
if the,
if the Chinese economy can be opened so
that currencies are a convertible,
Chinese tourists can take money and go
see the world.
Chinese businessman can go in and buy
property in the US and,
and,
and France and every place.
All of a sudden it's just going to be a
blossoming global economy.
I think it's going to be good for
everybody and I think the Chinese are
going to ultimately drive that because
they have a lot of money.
Many of them do now and they don't
really have an easy way to spend it.
They don't have an easy way to travel.
We,
when Japan was this big power in,
in the,
uh,
in,
in grew so rapidly in the,
in the eighties,
we saw Japanese tourists everywhere for
the first time.
It was the first thing we saw,
but we don't see this large influx of
Chinese tourists as what we would expect
to see.
And in New York is one place where you
might expect to see a lot more than a,
it's going to happen.
They travel all over China.
You go to China and you see it's all the
tourist spots are full of people,
but they're all Chinese tourists because
that's where they go.
That's,
you know,
they can't really go out of the country
very easily.
So I think it's going to be a happy day
for everybody in China and outside of
China when,
when this
orders are opened a little more.